THERE IS A DESPERATE
SEARCH AND RESCUE OPERATION
UNDER WAY ACROSS TURKEY AND
SYRIA AFTER A MASSIVE 7.8
MAGNITUDE EARTHQUAKE RIPPED
THROUGH THE TWO COUNTRIES BEFORE
DAWN.
THE DEATH TOLL NOW TOPS 2,700
AND WILL LIKE WILL KEEP RISING
AS CREWS DIG THROUGH THE RUBBLE.
MORE THAN 120 AFTERSHOCKS HIT
AFTER THE EARTHQUAKE, INCLUDING
ONE ALMOST AS POWERFUL AS THE
EARTHQUAKE ITSELF.
BUILDINGS CRUMBLED TO THE
GROUND.
PEOPLE FEARED TRAPPED INSIDE.
OTHERS HAVING TO RUN FOR THEIR
LIVES.
RESCUERS HAVING TO REACH THOSE
WHO ARE STUCK UNDER PILES OF
CONCRETE AND DEBRIS, LIKE THIS
BOY IN NORTHERN SYRIA.
YOU CAN JUST MAKE HIM OUT BURIED
UNDER THE WRECKAGE.
THANKFULLY HE WAS PULLED THE
SAFETY.
RESCUERS ALSO PULLING THIS
LITTLE GIRL FROM THE DEBRIS IN
ANOTHER SYRIAN CITY.
THE U.S. AND OTHER COUNTRIES ARE
OFFERING WHATEVER HELP THEY CAN.
AND PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID HE HAS
DIRECTED HIS TEAM TO PROVIDE ANY
AND ALL ASSISTANCE IMMEDIATELY.
CNN'S JUMANA IS IN TURTY.
TEAMS DEPLOYED THROUGHOUT THAT
CITY.
WHAT IS THE LATEST?
YOU HAVE BEEN REPORTING ALL DAY
FOR US.
>> Reporter: UTTER DEVASTATION
STRETCHING ACROSS TEN PROVINCES
IN SOUTHERN TURKEY AND ACROSS
THE BORDER.
IN SYRIA YOU'VE GOT IMPACTED
AREAS IN GOVERNMENT CONTROLLED
PARTS OF SYRIA AS WELL AS THE
VERY VULNERABLE PARTS OF SYRIA
THAT ARE UNDER OPPOSITION
CONTROL.
THESE ARE PARTS OF THE COUNTRY
WHERE YOU HAVE MORE THAN 4
MILLION PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
DISPLACED BY WAR, PEOPLE WHO HAD
NOTHING.
AND NOW THEY ARE FINDING
THEMSELVES IN THIS SITUATION,
AND THEY JUST DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES AND THE CAPABILITIES
TO DEAL WITH THIS DISASTER.
WE ARE GETTING INFORMATION EVERY
FEW MINUTES, THIS DEATH TOLL
THAT IS CONTINUING TO RISE,
ACCORDING TO TURKISH OFFICIALS,
MORE THAN 1,600 PEOPLE CONFIRMED
KILLED IN TURKEY.
MORE THAN A THOUSAND ALSO
CONFIRMED KILL IN THE SYRIA AS
WELL, AND YOU'VE GOT THE SEARCH
AND RESCUE OPERATIONS CONTINUING
WITH THOUSANDS OF BUILDINGS
DESTROYED, DAMAGED.
AND MANY, MANY BUILDING JUST
COMPLETELY FLATTENED ACROSS THIS
EARTHQUAKE ZONE.
IT'S A VERY, VERY COMPLEX AND
REALLY CHALLENGING SEARCH AND
RESCUE OPERATION.
THEY'RE FACING MANY CHALLENGES
RIGHTS NOW.
THE AFTERSHOCKS YOU MENTIONED,
MORE THAN 100 AFTERSHOCKS
REPORTED BY TURKISH OFFICIALS,
MAKING IT WERE, VERY DIFFICULT
FOR THE RESCUE CREWS TO RYE AND
PULL PEOPLE FROM UNDER THE
RUBBLE.
IT IS NIGHTTIME RIGHT NOW.
ALSO ANOTHER CHALLENGE.
AND THEN YOU'VE GOT THE WEATHER
CONDITIONS.
THERE'S A SEVERE WINTER STORM
THAT IS IMPACTING THAT PART OF
THE COUNTRY AS WELL AS MANY
PARTS OF TURKEY AS WELL.
ALSO IN SYRIA.
TEMPERATURES DROPPING TO
FREEZING, AND THEN YOU'VE GOT
SNOW, MAKING IT DIFFICULT FOR
THE CREWS TO REACH A LOT OF
THESE AREAS.
AGAIN, WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
MASSIVE AREA THAT'S IMPACTED AND
THEY ARE TRYING TO REACH AS MANY
AREA AS POSSIBLE.
AND REPORTS OF ROADS BLOCK IN
THE MANY AREAS.
ABSOLUTELY DEVASTATING SITUATION
AS WELL.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN THE
EARTHQUAKE ZONE BOTH IN SYRIA
AND TURKEY, AUTHORITIES ARE
SCRAMBLING TO SET UP SHELTERS
AND AWAITING THE INTERNATIONAL
RESPONSE FROM COUNTRIES IN
DIFFERENT ORGANIZATIONS,
INCLUDING NATO AND THE EU THAT
WILL BE SUPPORTING TURKEY
THROUGH THIS DISASTER.
>> SUCH HORRIFIC TO THE BEST OF
MY KNOWLEDGE -- ESPECIALLY THOSE
IMAGES OF THE CHILDREN THERE,
JUST HEARTBREAKING.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>>> JOINING ME NOW IS LUCY
JONES.
SHE'S A SEISMOLOGIST STUDYING
EARTHQUAKES AND THE FOUNDER AND
CHIEF SCIENTIST AT THE DR. LUCY
JONES CENTER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING
US.
WE KNOW TURKEY SITS BETWEEN
FAULT LINES AND SMALL TREMORS DO
HAPPEN QUITE OFTEN THERE, BUT
WERE YOU SURPRISED BY THE
MAGNITUDE OF THIS PARTICULAR
EARTHQUAKE?
>> NO.
WE KNOW THAT EARTHQUAKES OF THIS
SIZE HAVE HAPPENED IN THE PAST
IN TURKEY AND WILL CONTINUE TO,
BECAUSE WE CAN SEE THE FAULTS
THAT ARE CAPABLE OF IT.
THE MAGNITUDE IS DETERMINED BY
THE FAULT, IN THIS CASE 200
KILOMETERS FOR THE FIRST AND 100
FOR THE SECOND.
WE NOEVER KNOW WHAT THE TIME WIL
BE, BUT THE FACT IT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN IN SENSE WILL BE A
CERTAINTY.
>> AFTERSHOCKS CAN BE JUST AS
DEVASTATING.
AND KNOWING THE SECOND CAME OUT
AT 7.5, CAN WE EXPECT MORE
AFTERSHOCKS?
AND WHAT IMPACT DOES THIS HAVE
ON SEARCH AND RESCUE CREWS?
>> RIGHT, SEARCH AND RESCUE
CREWS REALLY HAVE TO TAKE THIS
EXTRA RISK INTO ACCOUNT.
WE LIKE TO SAY, WHEN YOU HAVE A
LOT OF EARTHQUAKES YOU TEND TO
HAVE A LOT OFFERS.
WHEN YOU HAVE AN ACTIVE
AFTERSHOCK SEQUENCE, WHICH IS
WHAT WE'RE SEEING HERE, IT WILL
CONTINUE TO BE MORE ACTIVE.
I'M SURE THEY'RE GOING TO SEE
MORE MAGNITUDE 6s.
THERE'S A POSSIBILITY FOR A 7.
THE FAULT ON WHICH IT HAPPENED
IS QUITE LONG, AND THERE CAN BE
CONTINUED EARTHQUAKES ON THE
NEXT SECTION OVER.
THE AFTERSHOCKS ARE DIAGNOSE
OFF.
THE FIRST DAY WILL HAVE MOST OF
THEM.
THE SECOND DAY WILL HAVE HALF.
THIRD DAY, WILL HAVE A THIRD.
IT'S A ONE OTHER TIME DECAY.
IT WILL BE GETTING BETTER.
IT WILL HAVE TO BE TAKEN INTO
ACCOUNT IN THE SEARCH AND
RESCUE.
>> YOU'RE SAYING THE AFTERSHOCKS
WILL CONTINUE TO BE FELT.
I KNOW THIS WAS THE WORST
EARTHQUAKE FOR TURKEY IN SOME 80
YEARS, BUT THE COUNTRY HAD
STRICT BUILDING CODES PUT INTO
PLACE SOME DECADES AGO.
CLEARLY THEY WEREN'T UP TO
STANDARDS.
HOW MUCH OF THE FAULT LIES WITH
THE GOVERNMENT ITSELF IN TERMS
OF SEISMOLOGISTS GIVING WARNINGS
THIS WAS TO COME, AND CERTAINLY
MANY OF THESE BUILDS WEREN'T UP
TO STANDARD?
>> DEPENDS ON EXACTLY WHY THE
BUILDINGS CAME DOWN.
BUILDING CODES ARE NOT
RETROACTIVE, SO IF THESE
BUILDINGS WERE BUILT BEFORE THE
CURRENT CODES COME INTO PLACE,
IT JUST DOESN'T PLAY.
SAME THING IS TRUE EVERYWHERE
ELSE AS WELL.
WE KNOW WE HAVE BUILDINGS THAT
ARE GOING TO COLLAPSE, BUT THAT
DOESN'T MAKE THEM DISAPPEAR.
COULD BE IT'S EITHER TOO OLD A
BUILDING, THAT SOMETHING IN THE
MODERN CODE DIDN'T TAKE
SOMETHING INTO ADVANCE.
THE ENGINEERS ARE GOING TO BE IN
THERE TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THAT.
THERE'S ALSO THE POSSIBILITY
THAT THE DESIGNS WERE NOT
FOLLOWED OR THE CONSTRUCTION OF
SUB STANDARD, AND THAT'S GOING
TO REQUIRE AN INVESTIGATION TO
DETERMINE WHY THE BUILDINGS
PERFORMED AS BADLY AS THEY DID.
>> TURKEY'S A LARGE COUNTRYING
BUT LAST YEAR THE URBAN
ENVIRONMENT MINISTER SAID 7
MILLION HOMES WERE AT RISK OF AN
EARTHQUAKE.
DOES THAT SOUND NORMAL TO YOU?
>> YES.
I MEAN, IT'S A DENSE COUNTRY.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF EARTHQUAKE
FAULTS.
AND THE BIG ISSUE, IS HOW CLOSE
ARE YOU TO HOW BIG THE
EARTHQUAKE IS?
IF YOU'RE 100 MILES AWAY, IT'S
NOT GOING TO BE THAT BAD, BUT IF
YOU'RE RIGHT ON TOP OF IT, IT
IS.
LOOKS LIKE 4.5 MILLION PEOPLE
CIRCUMSTANTIAL EVIDENCE SHAKING
STRONG MUST HAVE TO DESTROY AN
OLDER BUILDING, WHICH IS CALLED
INTENSITY 7.
IT'S NOT MAGNITUDE, BUT AN
INTENSITY SCALE.
4 HADN'T 5 MILLION PEOPLE
SUBJECTED TO IT JUST IN THE ONE
EARTHQUAKE.
THAT'S THE SORT OF NUMBER.
IT'S TRUE IN EVERY SEISMIC
AREA -- WE KNOW THAT OLD
BUILDINGS ARE A PROBLEM, AND IT
DOESN'T MAKE THEM DISAPPEAR.
>> THIS COMING AS THE WEATHER'S
IN FREEZING TEMPERATURE THERE
IS, AND AT 4:00 IN THE MORNING,
NOT GIVING FAMILIES MUCH WARNING
TO LEAVE THEIR HOMES FOR SAFETY.
LUCY JONES, THANKS SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME.
WE APPRECIATE IT.